uh should we really be paying the french
54 million quid
to do their jobs properly well good
morning kay and i think the pictures
you've just seen
uh are pictures that people across the
country
are getting increasingly frustrated
about and so we are acting both
at home but also importantly
internationally
to try to tackle this at home just last
night we were
um we passed away sorry we passed the
scrutiny stage of the
uh latest immigration bill to try to
really fix this broken asylum system and
the immigration system that we have
but importantly internationally it's
through agreements such as the one that
the home secretary struck last night
with france
that we will help to control the flow uh
coming over to us so
there was an agreement in november uh
where we paid for more police officers
on french beaches we believe that that
stopped about seven and a half thousand
people from making the trip across
and so this deal last night uh will
ensure
with the doubling of police officers on
the beach as well as
uh real improvements in surveillance
technology and other
other matters we really do believe that
this will be part of our solution to
this very very serious problem okay is
it the humanitarian thing to do
to threaten people who are risking their
lives to try to have a better life in
the uk
with four years in jail well is it the
humanitarian thing to do to allow people
smugglers
criminal gangs to exploit people
uh to bring them over in boats that are
simply not seaworthy i mean i've seen
for myself some of the
um dinghies that they're bringing many
many people over across the channel one
of the busiest well the busiest shipping
route in the world
and the huge risk to life that that
presents
so we're trying as i say to ensure that
we have an immigration system that is
firm but fair that we are opening up
safe
routes for people to come legally
through but also cracking down
on these criminal gangs that are
exploiting people's wishes
to come to this country yeah as you say
they're getting on these flimsy dinghies
because they're prepared to risk their
lives
because they want to move from the
countries where their lives are
at risk let alone the busiest shipping
lane in the world and all of the
challenges that that
causes and we're now saying if you
manage to do all of that
we're still going to put you in jail for
up to four years but the
important thing and i don't accept the
um proposition of your question but just
just taking a step back if someone is
seeking asylum
and they have come from a country a
conflict-ridden country
then by definition to get on that small
boat
they will have passed through at least
one safe country france germany and so
on
we've only to see that you know the
movement patterns across the eu
towards uh the french beaches and then
the boats coming across to see that
people don't seem to be taking up the
opportunity
to uh claim asylum and seek safety
in other eu countries in the eu that are
perfectly safe so that's
that's the message we've really got to
land with people that if you're if
you're landing
in the eu it's a safe um a set of
countries of course it is
please that is where you should be
seeking asylum
okay so don't come to the uk at all well
we have we will have open and safe
routes for people to come
legally so we have a proud record of
welcoming refugees
from some of the most conflicted areas
of the world uh we have welcomed tens of
thousands of people
over recent years uh we have programs to
help unaccompanied asylum seeking
children as well we take that very
seriously
um but we our message must be please you
cannot come to this
uh country illegally but because apart
from anything else
it's not fair on the people who are
trying to enter this country
legally who are playing by the rules and
uh and we welcome them with open arms
okay let's talk to me about apparently a
new slogan that the government is
launching call keep
life moving uh a new government slogan
to deal with covid19 and its aftermath
what does that actually mean
okay you'll have to forgive me i'm not a
health minister so i haven't heard that
phrase before
you've just used it now but what i do
know is that we're all really focused on
trying to
ensure that this in this stage of the
pandemic as we're easing the
restrictions
that we're doing so in a way that is
safe and secure because sadly
on the way out let me ask you about the
test and trace uh
app which you will know quite a lot
about um
is it really fit for purpose it looks as
though people according to the latest
yougov poll
uh 20 percent of people have just
switched it off and uh another third
have deleted it all together
we don't have those figures within the
system itself we know in fact that um
people hundreds of thousands of people
have joined it recently
and i think in terms of the app itself
look i know it's frustrating when people
have been pinged and they have to
self-isolate if they've been in contact
with someone who has covered um
and i really do understand the um
pressures that this is placing
on people and on businesses um but we
we're now in this new stage of our um
solutions for the pandemic
and the uh test and trace app is
one of the key tools that we have
isolation is one of the key tools we
have
to try to slow the spread of this virus
look we've got the the vaccine that that
has been an absolute game changer
but we okay we've got so much to talk
about so let's counter through if i may
i mean
we i was chatting to michael o'leary
earlier this week you know who he is of
course uh ryanair chief exec
he advised our viewers to completely
delete the app because it was pointless
i was speaking to a personal trainer
yesterday
and he said a lot of people in the gym
had put their phones in their lockers
while they worked out they were all
pinged
yes well i'm i'm not normally in the
habit of accepting mr o'leary's advice
and i'm not going to change
today um our very clear advice uh from
scientists is that self-isolation is one
of the key ways that we will manage
the pandemic look we all want to get out
of the restrictions we do you know
we want to try to get back to life as
normal as possible over the coming
months we've eased the restrictions this
week
we're asking people to um take
responsibility to use their personal
judgments
and the app and the test and trace
system as a whole is one of the ways in
which we managed this pandemic
i mean i think the ons has said that um
if you are in contact with a person who
is positive something like a third of
people who've been in contact
go on themselves to develop covert we
know that you're
about five times more likely to come
down with covert if you've been in that
close personal contact with someone who
has tested positive
so it's really just about trying to
manage the risk of positive
okay why doesn't the government give us
um a list
of key workers like you did last uh
march a year last march people that
could still go
to work when there was a lockdown the
first lockdown in the united kingdom why
don't we have a list of critical workers
so that is being worked on at the moment
i understand uh we made an
announcement on monday about uh certain
uh people who work for the nhs and um
in the care sector uh but uh we are that
a list of such workers is being worked
on because again we do
we have been listening we do understand
the implications that this is having for
certain
yeah you're saying being worked on but
you know we know that 1.7 million people
that's reported
have been pinged and are self-isolated
when you say being worked on it's not
that difficult given that you've already
had a list that you were working with
last march why don't you just say
let's put that back into place again so
you know bin men
can be exempt nursery and teaching staff
social workers
the justice system religious staff
journalists
why not well um just but
in the professions that you've just
listed there you can see how
suddenly the numbers are expanding and
so it is it's a different exercise from
the exercise of last year
uh in terms of key workers who can
return to their place of work
it's a slightly different exercise
because where the the scientists will
have to be con
uh calculating you know how many people
equals
uh risks in terms of um spreading the
spreading the virus around the country
so it is a it's a complicated exercise
but it is very much being worked on as i
say we made the first step this week
uh with our announcement in relation to
the nhs to that
end there's a story in the guardian
newspaper this morning that border
officials
will no longer be required to make basic
covey checks on arrivals
in england from green and amber list
countries
there'll be no need necessarily for
people to say where they will be
um isolating for their five or or ten
days
uh and there'll be no need for them to
prove on every occasion
uh when they're going to have their
tests is that government policy
i haven't been briefed on that so i that
that's again
not my portfolio area but what i do know
is that we
are uh applying the quality isn't it
border control is part of your remit no
all right border control part of your
remit no
horrible hidden harm so i've actually
come on the program to talk about
violence against women and girls
and we're going to talk about that but
you're the government minister
representing the government's policy
this morning
so if you could just uh offer me a view
on that it is in the papers this morning
i'm sure you had a look at them before
you came on
a specialist minister in those areas but
in terms of quarantine rules
we have again on monday we set out that
if you've been double vaccinated there
are changes in relation to ambulance
countries
and of course with redless countries
those rules still very much apply you
must not travel there
so it's not something that the
government would support uh loosening
the restrictions on ambulance countries
uh people coming in from those countries
into the uk
whether it's from france spain
potentially spain or other countries
with other countries there are i
understand a series of agreements that
have been set up
to ensure that uh vaccines overseas are
recognized
uh here and vice versa so you know
there's a lot of work that goes on
behind the scenes to try to ensure that
international travel can continue albeit
in a very very different way from
how we've understood it in years
previously as you said you
also want to talk about uh violence
against women and girls this morning
again reading in the papers a third of
universities are using
gagging uh clauses uh to prevent
students
speaking out about sexual assault what's
your advice on that
well we've today we're launching the
tackling violence against women and
girls strategy which is a radical
cross-government strategy to tackle
crimes that disproportionately affect
women and girls
we know from the national conversation
that
flared up earlier this year following
very very tragic events
just how much women and girls are
experiencing and have experienced in the
past
in terms of those sorts of crimes we
absolutely want to tackle them
these crimes are not inevitable and so
this document is a
huge document across as i say all
aspects of
national and local life in terms of
education we very much want to
work with education to ensure that we're
teaching
girls and boys really good healthy
attitudes in terms of relationships and
how
they're treating each other but also in
university we do
we're very concerned about allegations
of sexual harassment within
universities we want to ensure that
universities are
have a consistency and a quality of
standards that they're applying and we
are very looking very carefully at this
use of
ndas in some universities because we are
concerned about
uh how they could be used to cover up a
very very harmful practices within
universities
yeah uh let's stick with the subject of
uh women
how powerful is um carrie johnson a
supportive spouse
uh as some would see her or a shadowy
lady macbeth figure as she was
seen yesterday running the country while
her husband uh doesn't know how to do it
i think mrs johnson is um married to the
prime minister and she's a person in her
own right
i feel very uncomfortable when we tell
some people delve into descriptions such
as the one you've just used
she's a professional woman in her own
right she happens to be married to the
prime minister
and i think we should um just let her
get on with the job of
being married to the prime minister
frankly yeah but does that include
helping run the country no i mean number
10 have been
clear that uh some of the allegations
that were made in last night's interview
um that political appointments for
example are a matter solely for the
prime minister
um but i i don't know carrie but i know
friends who i have friend dear friends
who are friends with her and i know that
she is a
supportive wife as frankly every other
spouse of a prime minister has been
um i wonder if uh mr may got asked these
questions
you know that was the question i was
about to put to you and the fact that
you know do we treat
spices that are women different to
spices that are men
well i i having had the um
real privilege of not one but two female
prime ministers we're the only
uh party that has uh enabled that to
happen um i think it's fair to say that
well people will judge themselves if
there has been a difference in the
treatment between
the husbands of prime ministers as
opposed to the wives of prime ministers